[Music]
Reed thank you so much for being here
today really excited to be here thank
you for having me of course so let's
dive in talk to me about exactly what
your company does yeah so verad dermic
is a medical Dermatology company and
really the origin of the company was the
idea that there are more than 3,000 skin
conditions many of which have no FDA
approved treatment have had minimal
innovation in decades and there's
minimal innovation in the Horizon and so
we set out with the mindset that we
could leverage our enduser knowledge as
Physicians to identify treatments that
address real therapeutic challenges
within
Dermatology what was your your founding
story so the founding story is is
probably sillier than anything which is
that I was at an American Academy of
Dermatology meeting and I got nominated
to attend this pre-meeting for advancing
Innovation and dermatology which is an
organization that promotes physician
entrepreneurs and in inators at the
conference I heard about you know a
variety of events and one of them was an
event that they no longer do
unfortunately called hacking Dermatology
and I met my co-founder there and the
origin of the company was that basically
we're having breakfast he says to me you
know what if we could administer an
immune stimulant with what is
essentially Band-Aid that's a great idea
croissant falls out of my mouth and uh
yeah now it's 4 years later we had five
products the lead products are for
pattern hair loss also known as
androgenetic alopecia and for common
work tell me about your funding Journey
was it hard to convince investors to
take a chance on you and how much have
you raised so far so we've raised nearly
$40 million and I think we've been
incredibly fortunate in that identifying
many of our critical investors has
occurred very serendipitously you know
not necessarily through these
intentional approaches that we all
employ to raise Capital but just during
day-to-day interactions and the original
roughly $2 million we raised all came
came from Physicians so more than 25
Physicians they said hey we recognize
that warts for problem we recognize that
these other dermatologic conditions need
treatment and they believed in the team
and investing in us and that support
then translated into more of a
traditional Venture round I think people
saw that we weren't paying our K's they
were investing in us and that was really
exciting and different Journey for for
most of the investors we were then
fortunate to get the backing of of of Dr
Vlad kich who is the the CEO of biohaven
and and John child who's the the
managing director of JW child's
Associates now a little bit of a fun one
for you if you could travel back in time
and if you could tell yourself one piece
of advice the day before you started
your company what would you say oo that
is a good question I think that the
answer to that is likely not everybody
gives good advice we have some
tremendous thought Partners I've got to
work with some of the leading Minds in
the industry people who have been very
generous with their time to you know
help in migr growth to Mentor me and to
Mentor the company but it is interesting
because as you move through each phase
of the company the thought leaders or
the thought partners that you need are
very very different and I don't think I
appreciated how someone who is really
Savvy at the seed stage may not
necessarily understand the series be
your crossover stage and then may not
necessarily understand what does it take
to take a company public and having the
right people at the right time to assist
you is just
critical is there one business rule that
you operate by no matter
what I approach all our interactions as
though the other person has a piece of
information that I don't know that I
need to get and you know there are lots
of times where I think it's easier to
tell people tell people tell people and
not ask and everyone in the room is
sitting there they know something you
don't know or they're thinking something
they're all thinking the same thing when
you walk out of the room and so I try to
approach everything with a lot of
questions I think my team would would
say that every interaction with me is is
20 questions but but I I found that to
be super effective I feel like I've
learned a lot and I feel like I often
walk out of a room with a very different
outcome than I
anticipated and one last question for
you Reed what would you like your legacy
to be that's a that's a very difficult
question and you know I think at the end
of the day most of what we are doing is
about Building Product and it's about
building something that has actual value
to the people who use it
and I would hope that those products
would become synonymous with the
conditions and would really take away
these therapeutic challenges that we're
trying to
[Music]
address